we now come to the leader of the snp in
blackford
thank you mr speaker can i associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition and supporting our carers
mr speaker
week after week
i've called on this prime minister to
resign i've been met with a wall of
noise from the tory benches i thought
they were trying to
shout me down but all this time
[Applause]
but all this time mr speaker it turns
out that 41 of them have been cheering
me on
because
mr speaker let's be clear at least the
numbers don't lie
41
of his own mps have no confidence in
them 66 of mps across the house don't
support him and 97
of scottish mps want the minister for
the union showing the door
we now have a lame duck prime minister
presiding over a divided party in a dis
united kingdom
how does the prime minister
expect to continue when even unionist
leaders in scotland won't back them yeah
prime minister i want to thank my uh
right honourable gentleman for his
characteristic uh warm words uh and just
actually mr speaker i want to say that
the biggest and most powerful and
effective advocate of the united kingdom
over the last uh time that i've been in
has been that man now
under his i don't know how long he's
going to last uh here as leader of the
snp
long may long may he rest in place mr
speaker he is the araldite that's
keeping our kingdom uh together
[Applause]
[Music]
shoulder to shoulder with our first
minister as we take our country to
independence
mr speaker
the prime minister
is acting like monty python's black
knight running around declaring it's
just a flesh wound
no amount of delusion and denial will
save the prime minister from the truth
this story won't go away until he goes
away for once in his life
he needs to wake up to reality
prime minister it's over it's done
the prime minister
has no options left but scotland does
has the choice of an independent future
[Music]
it's not just the prime minister that we
have zero confidence in it's the broken
westminster system that puts a man like
him in power
can the prime minister tell us how it is
democratic that scotland is stuck with a
prime minister we don't trust a
conservative party we don't support and
tony governments we haven't voted for
since 1955.
prime minister uh mr speaker we had a we
had a referendum as i've told guys
before uh in 2014 i think he should
respect the mandate of the of the people
and you know he keeps saying he keeps
saying that uh he was he
he wants his independence for his
country our country is independent uh mr
speaker
our country is independent
he then he tried 48 times to reverse it
to the
the
and the only way that independence would
ever be reversed is we had the disaster
mr speaker of a labor snp coalition to
take us back into the eu